just days before King Charles's
coronation in court documents filed
yesterday Prince Harry claims his
brother Prince William quietly received
a large Financial settlement at a 2020
phone hacking case against British
newspapers Harry is suing Rupert
Murdoch's newspaper group and alleges
the Royals had a secret agreement that's
a quote with the press to settle
Williams case and avoid embarrassing
coverage boy MTS retired reports from
London
Prince Harry's claim his brother Prince
William had a case against Rupert
Murdoch's newspaper group that was
settled for a large sum is one of a
series of explosive Revelations made in
his witness statement
but the court filings have raised
questions about other possible secret
deals between the Royals I'm sorry and
Britain's tabloid press says former son
tabloid newspaper editor Kelvin McKenzie
there would definitely be in on Harry's
side a sense that there was a cozy
cartel between uh the popular papers and
the royal family so he wants to blow
this up he gets back in his own family
he he bashes the tabloids over the head
he gives Murdoch a kick in the pants
there is nothing not to like as far as
Harry is concerned the palace is not
commenting on the case in which Prince
Harry alleges since the mid-2000s he's
been the victim of phone hacking and
other illegal behavior that generated
headlines which have destroyed some of
his personal relationships accusing
reporters who worked for Rupert
Murdoch's tabloid newspapers of
illegally accessing his voicemails to
obtain private information about him
over the past decade Murdoch owned
businesses have settled several similar
phone hacking claims for hundreds of
millions of dollars in Damages it's
pretty clear that they are going to do
everything they can not to go to court
no matter what Prince Harry wants Rupert
model never goes into the witness box
and he'll do everything everything to
stop either him or his other Executives
in London from being cross-questioned
it's a very very big game that's going
on in London right now precipious
morning Sim in London
I thought what was even more interesting
is Harry revealed that his grandmother
Queen Elizabeth II was aware of this
settlement of the settlement yes